- [Kelly] Well,
the series finale of
Supergirl is in a few weeks.
So did you keep anything from
the show? And by that, I mean,
did you steal anything?
- [Melissa] I did. I took a
few things, but no, there,
for some reason the props department,
I think found like a tub of
dinosaur figurines somewhere
and they would just put
them in random places
of the CatCo office set.
- Wait, what?
- I don't know.
So I would see them and I had
this weird love of dinosaurs
as a child. We all
loved dinosaurs as kids,
but my love of dinosaurs lasted...
- I loved them as adults in movies
that his daughter is in, Jurassic World.
(group chattering)
- [Melissa] Me too, me too.
Actually Jurassic Park was
a huge reason I loved them.
- [Kelly] Because it's
an amazing franchise.
- But I wanted to be a paleontologist.
- [Kelly] Oh, you were in it?
- Yeah, I was in it
until my parents took
us to Dinosaur Ridge in
Colorado, which is a live dig
and I saw how boring it was.
(audience laughing)
- Paleontologist everywhere
were like "whatever"